I just think it's kind of funny that
Alec Baldwin gets his charges dropped
you know and he's the one who shot the
lady and then the other lady the armorer
still has the charges and she didn't
even hold the gun pull the trigger she
should have thought of that before she
had didn't have her millionaire lawyers
that is her fault yeah yeah she should
have considered being a millionaire and
having better lawyers well I'm sure she
got the job I'm surprised that you're
surprised to be honest like to me this
was duh I'm like surprised that you
thought there was a chance that he was
going down like doing time well not so
much that he would do time but like that
they would slap him on the wrist with
something and at least at least feign
that they actually hold people
accountable for shooting people in the
chest and killing them I think this was
the extent of it it was just this
whatever these charges were right this
was his punishment to go hey this is
scary huh I I actually think he did it
like my opinion of the matter is that he
intentionally murdered this woman
premeditated murder he had he had the
bullets on him everyone's like where did
the bolts go do a documentary about this